economía en directo américa hoy viernes
y ya está en el estudio como siempre
todas las mañanas daniela blandón danny
bienvenida a buena mañana como amaneció
hoy descanso si he descansado mucho esta
semana como todo el mundo pero
descansado pero pues por lo menos ahí
vamos durmiendo ya salimos a descansar
estos dos días que quedan de semana
santa para todos los católicos danny
crece en los temores de que rusia esté
encaminado hacia el de pueblo hemos
venido también tocando en nuestra
sección económica en directo américa
claro que si raúl y es que mire moody's
se sumó a las otras dos mayores
calificadoras de riesgo que son standard
and poor's y fitch ratings en su
apreciación de que si rusia no paga sus
obligaciones de deuda externa en dólares
se va a enfrentar a un incumplimiento o
default o como también se le conoce
independientemente de que cuente con el
dinero en rublos y es que el pasado 4 de
abril recordemos vencieron dos
obligaciones por unos 650 millones de
dólares rusia dijo haber hecho arreglos
para pagar en su moneda local porque no
tiene cómo acceder a gran parte de sus
reservas internacionales esto por las
sanciones occidentales
el kremlin tiene entonces un periodo de
gracia hasta el 4 de mayo para que sus
acreedores declaren si aceptan o no este
pago de todas formas moody's advierte
que los contratos de bonos abro comillas
no prevén el pago de ninguna otra moneda
que no sea en dólar cierro comillas si
moscú es declarado en default raúl sería
la primera vez desde 1917 en los años
posteriores a la revolución bolchevique
que se enfrenta a un incumplimiento de
pago danny y también twitter ha sido
noticia toda esta semana que es lo más
reciente bueno recordemos primero que la
propuesta del multimillonario hilo en
mosca para comprar el 100% de twitter
pues fue presentada en las últimas horas
pero pareció no gustarles mucho a los
inversionistas que castigaron la acción
el jueves con un descenso cercano al 2%
la empresa solamente dijo que analizaría
la oferta que en términos económicos se
define como hostil es decir que no es
solicitada y que los accionistas bien
podrían rechazar pero hoy la noticia es
otra usted le suena el nombre sí no
tengo un vago recuerdo pero la verdad no
a nadie le suena pero lo que sí suena es
que en marzo de 2021 este empresario de
las cripto monedas fue noticia porque
pagó 2.9 millones de dólares por una en
el df del primer tweet de la historia lo
vemos en pantalla en este el ex fundador
el fundador de twitter jack dorsey
anunció que estaba configurando su
cuenta pues hace unos días de raúl esta
vez sacó a la venta ese mismo nfc es por
48 millones de dólares pero en esta
primera semana recibió ofertas por
apenas cientos de dólares lo máximo que
le han ofrecido en 6 mil 800 dólares y
para que no saque la calculadora yo ya
le tengo la cuenta siete mil veces menos
de lo que pide y 400 veces menos de lo
que pagó hace un año y sabe cuál fue la
respuesta del dueño cual fue pues dijo
en esta misma red social no lo voy a
vender por ahora
igual igual perdió no ahora recordemos
any que es un ntf rápidamente mire
también conocido como token no fungible
según ene efe yo siempre me confundo
todos nos confundimos rcn ft es un
cripto activo que puede registrar la
propiedad de un archivo digital como una
imagen en un vídeo un texto y lleva
meses tomando mucha fuerza entre los
inversionistas danny el precio del juego
se dispara por la gripe aviar en francia
y también en eeuu siguen los alimentos
al alza esta vez no por la guerra sino
por la gripe aviar también todo está
grave si se agravan el uno con el otro
pues estos brotes de enfermedades a
enfermedad gripe aviar están reduciendo
el suministro mundial de huevos y
elevando los precios del alimento a
medida que la tierra en ucrania pues
también interrumpe estos envíos a europa
y oriente medio la situación es
particularmente difícil ahora que la
demanda sube por cuenta de las
festividades de pascua y es que la gripe
aviar ha acabado con más de 19 millones
de gallinas ponedoras en la unión
americana este año esto supondría el
peor brote desde 2015 mientras tanto
francia que es el mayor productor de la
unión europea se está está atravesando
el peor brote de su historia y ha
sacrificado alrededor del 8 por ciento
de las gallinas ponedoras como ha
impactado esta situación al bolsillo de
las personas como siempre los más
afectados claro que si los precios al
mayor de los huevos en el medio oeste de
estados unidos superaron en marzo de los
3 dólares por docena este es un segundo
nivel más alto de la historia y es el
triple de lo que costaba un año antes
ahora nos vamos para francia los precios
de los huevos al por mayor han subido un
69 por ciento desde el año pasado según
la oficina agrícola de ese país y como
los resultados pues los consumidores
podrían ver encarecimiento de los
productos alimenticios elaborados con
huevos como la mayonesa o el mismo pan
francés estático que podríamos tener una
pascua sin huevos también saber qué va a
pasar cifra el día a danny nos mire las
ganancias de las grandes instituciones
financieras de eeuu en el primer
trimestre de 2022 que cayeron
drásticamente
contrario a lo que se vio en pandemia
cuando se dispararon la guerra y el alza
de tasas de interés ahora los afectan de
todas maneras estos
55 bancos jpmorgan citigroup
y morgan stanley y wells fargo también
recordaron en su conjunto más de 23.000
millones de dólares en ganancias danny
gracias entonces por toda la información
económica el día de hoy nos vemos el
lunes con más economía en directo
américa